THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON LOCAL
GOVERNMENT WILL COME TO ORDER.
GOOD MORNING TO EVERYONE. THANK
YOU FOR JOINING US FOR THIS
MEETING OF THE SENATE COMMITTEE
ON LOCAL GOVERNMENT. WE WELCOME
THE WELCOME THE PUBLIC IN
PERSON. AND WE ARE HOLDING OUR
COMMITTEE HEARINGS HERE IN THE Þ
STREET BUILDING. I ASK ALL
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE TO BE
PRESENT IN ROOM 2200 SO WE CAN
ESTABLISH OUR QUORUM AND BEGIN
OUR HEARING. THIS IS OUR FIRST
HEARING FOR ASSEMBLY BILLS. WE
WILL HAVE FOUR ADDITIONAL
HEARINGS ON JUNE 5TH, JUNE 11TH,
JUNE 26TH AND JULY THIRD, THIRD,
THIRD. I'M NOT COMING ON JULY
4TH. YOU MIGHT BE COMING. THIS
IS THE LAST DAY. NO WAY. THIS IS
JULY 3RD, WE EXPECT ALL OF THOSE
HEARINGS TO GO FAIRLY LONG. THEY
DON'T HAVE TO, BUT THEY MIGHT,
AS THE COMMITTEE EXPECTS TO BE
REFERRED OVER 80 ASSEMBLY BILLS.
SO GET USED TO SEEING THIS
INSIDE OF OUR HEARING ROOM. WE
HAVE 11 BILLS ON TODAY'S AGENDA
WITH FIVE BILLS ON CONSENT. THE
FOLLOWING FIVE BILLS ARE ON
CONSENT. ITEM THREE AB 1852 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PACHECO. ITEM
FIVE AB 1957 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WILSON ON ITEM SEVEN AB 2213 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLANCA RUBIO.
ITEM NINE AB 2748 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FLORA AND ITEM 11 AB 1332
77 BY THE COMMITTEE ON LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. DO WE HAVE? YES, WE
DO RIGHT THREE. YEAH. NO QUORUM,
NO QUORUM. BUT YOU CAN START AS
A SUBCOMMITTEE. OKAY WE DON'T
HAVE A QUORUM YET, SO IT WILL
OPERATE AS AS A SUBCOMMITTEE. SO
NOW WE'RE GOING TO HEAR FROM OUR
FIRST AUTHOR, ASSEMBLY MEMBER,
NØ WALLACE. WALLACE. OKAY, OKAY,
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WALLACE. GOOD
MORNING. WELCOME. WELL, GOOD
MORNING, CHAIR DURAZO AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I HAVE
BEFORE YOU AB 491, WHICH WILL
ENHANCE LOCAL ENFORCEMENT
MECHANISMS FOR UNLICENSED
CANNABIS ACTIVITIES. SINCE
CALIFORNIA VOTERS MADE
RECREATIONAL CANNABIS LEGAL IN
2016 WITH PROPOSITION 64, THE
LEGISLATURE, AS WELL AS STATE
AND LOCAL JURISDICTIONS, HAVE
STRUGGLED TO DRIVE UNLAWFUL
OPERATORS OUT OF THE CANNABIS
MARKET. RURAL COMMUNITIES HAVE
BEEN INUNDATED WITH UNLICENSED
AND UNREGULATED CANNABIS
ACTIVITY THAT'S UNDERMINING THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY OF RESIDENTS
AND OUR REGULATED CANNABIS
BUSINESSES. COUNTIES AND CITIES
OFTEN USE CODE ENFORCEMENT WHEN
DEALING WITH UNLICENSED CANNABIS
ACTIVITIES. HOWEVER, THE
EXISTING PENALTY STATUTES WERE
PRIMARILY DESIGNED FOR ORDINARY
ZONING AND BUSINESS VIOLATIONS,
AND THESE PROCESSES ARE NOT
ALWAYS WELL SUITED FOR
ADDRESSING LARGE SCALE ILLEGAL
COMMERCIAL CANNABIS OPERATIONS.
AB 481 WILL BOLSTER BOLSTER
LOCAL ENFORCEMENT EFFORTS AND
ENABLE JURISDICTIONS TO ADDRESS
THIS ILLEGAL ACTIVITY MORE
EFFICIENTLY BY FIRST PROVIDING
FOR STREAMLINED JUDICIAL REVIEW
FOR MINOR ADMINISTRATIVE
PENALTIES. THOSE UNDER $25,000
IMPOSED FOR UNPERMITTED CANNABIS
ACTIVITIES. SECOND, ALLOWING
EFFICIENT COLLECTION OF FINAL
PENALTY ORDER AFTER
ADMINISTRATIVE AND OR JUDICIAL
REVIEW IS COMPLETE IN THE SAME
MANNER PRESENTLY USED FOR
PESTICIDE ENFORCEMENT FINES.
THIRD, BY CLARIFYING THAT
PRIORITY OF REAL PROPERTY HAVE
THE SAME PRIORITY AS A JUDGMENT
LIEN, I'M HAPPY. HAPPY TO ACCEPT
THE THOUGHTFUL COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS TO LIMIT THE NEW
COLLECTION MECHANISM TO CANNABIS
HOUSING AND FIRE HAZARD
PENALTIES, AND CLARIFYING
LANGUAGE TO ENSURE JUDICIAL
REVIEW HAS BEEN EXHAUSTED BEFORE
ENFORCEMENT ACTION IS TAKEN.
WITH THAT, I'D LIKE TO INTRODUCE
MY WITNESS, SARAH DUCKETT,
POLICY ADVOCATE FOR OUR CRC. THE
SPONSOR OF AB 491. GOOD MORNING.
GOOD MORNING, CHAIR AND MEMBERS,
SARAH DUCKETT, ON BEHALF OF THE
RURAL COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA, THE STRONG SUPPORT
OF AB 491, LIKE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WALLACE MENTIONED, RURAL
COMMUNITIES PARTICULARLY ARE
DEALING WITH A LOT OF
UNREGULATED CANNABIS BUSINESSES,
WHICH IS IMPACTING BOTH OUR
LEGAL MARKET AND THE PUBLIC
HEALTH AND SAFETY. AND WE'VE
BEEN REALLY UTILIZING CODE
ENFORCEMENT. WE DON'T WANT TO
CRIMINALIZE THIS. WE WANT TO BE
ABLE TO USE OUR CIVIL REMEDIES
TO ADDRESS THE SITUATION. BUT
CODE ENFORCEMENT REALLY WASN'T
BUILT FOR THESE TYPE OF
VIOLATIONS, THE PROCESS IS NOT
REALLY WELL SUITED FOR THESE
LARGE SCALE OPERATIONS. SO AB
491 AIMS TO DO A FEW THINGS.
FIRST, REQUIRE FOR MINOR
ADMINISTRATIVE PENALTIES IMPOSED
FOR UNPERMITTED CANNABIS
ACTIVITIES, THAT THE
ADMINISTRATIVE APPEALS PROCESS
WITHIN THE LOCAL ORDINANCE IS
THE EXCLUSIVE MEANS OF JUDICIAL
REVIEW. THIS WOULD STREAMLINE
THE PROCESS AS COMPARED TO CIVIL
LITIGATION, GIVEN THAT THIS IS
NOT A STANDARD CODE VIOLATION,
IT'S A LUCRATIVE. IT'S CLEAR IF
SOMEONE IS LICENSED OR EVEN IN
THE PROCESS OF BEING LICENSED,
AND THERE ARE SOME PRETTY,
PRETTY BIG PUBLIC HEALTH
CONCERNS, BOTH FOR THE COMMUNITY
MEMBERS IMPACTED, BUT ALSO THE
PRODUCT THAT IS GOING TO
CALIFORNIANS AND THE REST OF THE
COUNTRY THAT MAY BE HARMFUL IN
PARTICULARLY IN URBAN AREAS. WE
ALSO SEE A TYPICALLY A HIGH
CASELOAD AT YOUR COURTS, WHICH
CAN FURTHER DELAY THE PROCESS
AND ALLOW THEM TO REALLY BUMP
OUT THE TIME PERIODS, FINISH
GROWING, TRIMMING, MANUFACTURE
AND MOVE THAT CROP PRODUCT
BEFORE WE CAN ACTUALLY ADDRESS
THE ISSUE. SECOND, THE BILL
MIRRORS WHAT WE CURRENTLY USE
FOR PESTICIDE ENFORCEMENT FINES
AND ALLOWS THE JURISDICTION TO
FILE AN ORDER FOR A MONEY
JUDGMENT FILED WITH THE SUPERIOR
COURT CLERK FOR UNPAID FINES,
RATHER THAN BRING A CIVIL CASE.
WE APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEE'S
THOUGHTFUL AMENDMENTS TO LIMIT
THIS NEW AUTHORITY TO JUST
CANNABIS, STATE HOUSING LAW AND
FIRE HAZARDS, AND THAT THIS IS
THIS AUTHORITY, EXCEPT IN THE
CASE OF CANNABIS, CAN BE USED
AFTER ALL APPEAL AVENUES HAVE
BEEN EXHAUSTED. AND THIRD, THE
BILL CLARIFIES THAT DURING THE
COLLECTIONS PROCESS THAT ONCE A
COPY OF THE NOTICE OF LIEN IS
RECORDED IN THE COUNTY
RECORDER'S OFFICE, THE LIEN HAS
THE SAME FORCE EFFECT AND
PRIORITY AS A JUDGMENT LIEN,
WHICH WE BELIEVE IS CONSISTENT
WITH EXISTING CASE LAW. THIS
BILL BEFORE YOU IS A NARROWLY
TAILORED APPROACH TO STREAMLINE
AND PROVIDE MUCH NEEDED TOOLS TO
ADDRESS UNLICENSED CANNABIS
INFRACTIONS, AND FOR THESE
REASONS, WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR IPHONE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH, LEAD WITNESSES,
SUPPORT, OKAY. COME ON. GOOD
MORNING, MADAM CHAIR. MEMBERS
JEAN HURST HERE TODAY ON BEHALF
OF THE SANTA CLARA COUNTY BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS, WE ARE A PROUD
CO-SPONSOR OF THE MEASURE. AND
WHILE MISS TUCKER REFERENCED
RURAL COMMUNITIES, WE DO HAVE
PORTIONS OF OUR COUNTY THAT THIS
WOULD PROVIDE SOME, MUCH NEEDED
TOOLS TO ADDRESS CODE
ENFORCEMENT CHALLENGES THAT
WE'RE FACING AT THE LOCAL LEVEL.
WE APPRECIATE YOUR VOTE. THANK
YOU. MADAM CHAIR, MEMBERS,
JULIAN MORRIS, ON BEHALF OF THE
LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA CITIES AND
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. WE'RE GOING TO
STOP RIGHT HERE. JUST A MOMENT.
MR. ASSEMBLY MEMBER, SO WE CAN
TAKE QUORUM. SENATORS. DURAZZO.
DURAZZO. PRESIDENT SUHARTO HERE.
SUHARTO. PRESENT. DOLLY. DOLLY.
PRESENT GLAZER. SKINNER. WAHAB.
WAHAB. PRESENT WIENER, YOU HAVE
A QUORUM. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OKAY. ARE THERE ANY OTHERS HERE
TO SUPPORT AB 491? OKAY. ANY
ANYONE HERE OPPOSED TO AB 491
OKAY. SEEING NONE, MEMBERS,
ANYBODY WISHING TO COMMENT OR
QUESTIONS? NO SEEING NONE. I'LL
MOVE THE BILL. THANK YOU, THANK
YOU. SENATOR SUGIARTO. CLOSING
REMARKS, THANK YOU AGAIN.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. OKAY THE MOTION
IS DO PASS, AS AMENDED, TO
JUDICIARY. SENATORS DURAZZO I
DURAZZO. I CIERTO CIERTO I DOLLY
DOLLY I GLAZER. SKINNER. WAHAB
WAHAB I WIENER 4 TO 0. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. WE'LL LEAVE IT OPEN.
OKAY. I'LL MOVE. CONSENT SHE
WANTS TO MOVE CONSENT. OH. THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. OKAY. MOTION
TO APPROVE THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
SENATORS DURAZZO I DURAZZO I
CIERTO CIERTO I DOLLY. DOLLY I
GLAZER. SKINNER. WAHAB. WAHAB I
WIENER 4 TO 0. WE'LL LEAVE THAT
OPEN. ALL RIGHT, NEXT IS AB 761
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRIEDMAN.
GOOD MORNING, ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING, MADAM
CHAIR. AND MEMBERS, UNDER
CURRENT LAW, ENHANCE
INFRASTRUCTURE FINANCING
DISTRICTS. I FDS MAY ONLY
COLLECT TAX INCREMENT FOR UP TO
45 YEARS FROM THE DATE OF THE
FIRST BOND ISSUANCE. HOWEVER,
BECAUSE OF THE RELATIVELY SLOW
APPRECIATION AND PROPERTY VALUES
IN MANY CASES IT MAY TAKE 10 TO
15 YEARS BEFORE REVENUES ARE
SUFFICIENT TO BORROW AGAINST OR
BEGIN PAYING DOWN DEBT. AB 761
EXTENDS THE PERIOD OF THE
AVAILABLE TAX INCREMENT FROM 45
YEARS TO 75 YEARS TO ALIGN THE
TERM WITH THAT OF THE OF A
FEDERAL TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE, FINANCE AND
INNOVATION, WHICH IS TIFIA LOAN
WHICH IS ADMINISTERED BY THE US
DEPARTMENT OF TRANSPORTATION. AT
ITS CORE, WITH THIS BILL DOES IS
IT LINES OUR STATE PROGRAMS WITH
THE FEDERAL PROGRAMS. SO THAT
OUR CITIES AND MUNICIPALITIES
CAN CAN GET THE FEDERAL LOAN,
THIS DOING THIS WOULD ALLOW THE
EAFD A JOINT POWERS AUTHORITY,
BEING A TRANSIT AGENCY OR
INDIVIDUAL MEMBER JURISDICTIONS,
TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THE
FLEXIBLE TERMS OF A FEDERAL TIF
ALONE, WHICH MAY FUND UP TO 49%
OF A PROJECT'S COSTS AND USE
FUTURE TAX INCREMENT TO REPAY
THE LOAN. LA METRO AND LOS
ANGELES AREA MUNICIPALITIES ARE
EXPLORING THE UTILIZATION OF
THESE LOANS FOR A NUMBER OF
LOCAL PASSENGER RAIL PROJECTS.
LA METRO IS IN THE MIDDLE OF ONE
OF THE LARGEST REGIONAL TRANSIT
EXPANSION PROGRAMS IN THE
NATION, AND ALTHOUGH MOST
PROJECTS ARE FUELED BY A
COMBINATION OF LOCAL COUNTYWIDE
SALES TAX AND STATE OR FEDERAL
GRANTS, RISING PROJECT'S COSTS
ARE LIMITING THE PACE OF THAT
EXPANSION, MEANING MORE SUPPORT
FROM LOCAL CITIES AND COUNTIES
WILL BE NEEDED TO KEEP THE
PROJECTS AND CLIMATE GOALS ON
SCHEDULE. AB 761 IS NARROWLY
TAILORED TO APPLY TO DISTRICTS
FORMED AFTER JANUARY 1ST, 2025,
FOR THE PURPOSE OF FINANCING AND
CONSTRUCTING PASSENGER RAIL
PROJECTS THROUGH A FEDERAL TIFIA
LOAN. IT ALSO ENSURES THAT 45
YEARS AFTER THE ISSUANCE OF THE
LOAN, ALL TAX INCREMENT WILL BE
USED FOR THE REPAYMENT OF THAT
LOAN. IT GIVES LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS A TOOL TO FUND
MUCH NEEDED TRANSIT PROJECTS
THAT WILL SUPPORT LOCAL AND
STATE TRANSPORTATION. GREENHOUSE
GAS REDUCTION GOALS. WITH ME
TODAY TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT IS
JOHN ERICKSON, THE MAYOR OF THE
GREAT CITY OF WEST HOLLYWOOD,
AND JUSTIN ORENSTEIN,
TRANSPORTATION AND LEGISLATIVE
AFFAIRS DEPUTY FOR LA COUNTY
SUPERVISOR LINDSEY HORVATH. AND
WITH THAT, I WOULD URGE AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU, WHO WILL GO
FIRST? OKAY, THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR. AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS JUSTIN
ORNSTEIN, AND I'M THE
TRANSPORTATION DEPUTY FOR LA
COUNTY SUPERVISOR AND LA METRO
BOARD DIRECTOR, LINDSAY HORVATH,
THE SUPERVISOR WAS CALLED AWAY
ON COUNTY BUSINESS, BUT ASKED ME
TO EXTEND A TREMENDOUS
APPRECIATION TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRIEDMAN FOR AUTHORING AB 761,
TO YOU, MADAM CHAIR, FOR SEEING
THE IMPORTANCE OF THIS BILL AND
FOR YOUR CONTINUED WORK TO HELP
REALIZE THE TRANSIT AND
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION GOALS
OF THE LA REGION, AND TO EACH OF
THE MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE
FOR THEIR CONSIDERATION. LA LA
METRO, THE COUNTY OF LOS
ANGELES, AND CITIES LIKE LA AND
WEST HOLLYWOOD HAVE BEEN ENGAGED
IN EFFORTS TO EXPAND RAIL
SERVICE FOR YEARS. UNFORTUNATELY
THESE JURISDICTIONS ARE FACING
CHALLENGES NOT UNLIKE THOSE OF
AGENCIES AROUND THE STATE. SINCE
2016, WE'VE SEEN AN 83% INCREASE
IN THE PRICE OF STEEL, A 50%
INCREASE IN THE PRICE OF
CONCRETE, A 37% INCREASE IN THE
PRICE OF MACHINERY AND EQUIPMENT
. THIS, COUPLED WITH A LULL IN
SALES TAX GROWTH, THE FTA'S NEW
CONTINGENCY REQUIREMENTS AND A
TIGHT CONSTRUCTION LABOR MARKET
ARE ALL SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASING
PROJECT COSTS. METRO IS DOING
WHAT IT CAN TO IDENTIFY
EFFICIENCIES AND ALTER PROJECT
SCOPES WHERE POSSIBLE, BUT
MACROECONOMIC PRESSURES REMAIN.
WE TOOK A CLOSE LOOK AT WAYS
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS COULD HELP
FINANCE REGIONAL TRANSPORTATION
PROJECTS, AND ONE OF THOSE TOOLS
IS ENHANCED INFRASTRUCTURE
FINANCING DISTRICTS. AND WHILE
EFDS CAN GENERATE SIGNIFICANT
REVENUES, THE MAJORITY OF THOSE
REVENUES COME AFTER THE FIRST 15
YEARS. THIS IS PROBLEMATIC FOR
LARGE FOR LARGE TRANSIT
PROJECTS, WHICH CAN'T ACQUIRE
FINANCING UNTIL SUFFICIENT
REVENUES EXIST. HOWEVER, FEDERAL
TIFIA LOANS CAN BE STRUCTURED IN
WAYS THAT TRADITIONAL FINANCING
CANNOT. THIS INCLUDES NO
PAYMENTS UNTIL FIVE YEARS AFTER
PROJECT COMPLETION, INTEREST
ONLY PAYMENTS, AND LONGER
FINANCING TERMS. WHILE THIS BILL
MIGHT SEEM TO MAKE A MINOR
TECHNICAL CHANGE, IT PROVIDES
FOR SIGNIFICANT POTENTIAL
OUTCOMES. BY MAKING THIS CHANGE
TO EXTEND THE PERIOD OF APHIDS
FROM 45 TO 75 YEARS FOR
PASSENGER RAIL PROJECTS, WE
COULD SEE LOWER ANNUAL PAYMENTS,
INCREASE FINANCING CAPACITY AND
APHIDS AS MORE VIABLE TOOLS FOR
JURISDICTIONS PURSUING CRITICAL
TRANSIT INVESTMENTS. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION AND HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE. THANK YOU, MR. ERICKSON.
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR, AND
MEMBERS OF THE SENATE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY IN FRONT
OF YOU ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
WEST HOLLYWOOD. MY NAME IS JOHN
ERICKSON, AND I'M THE MAYOR OF
THAT GREAT CITY, WEST HOLLYWOOD
HAS PURSUED RAIL SERVICE FOR AT
LEAST 20 YEARS. THIS EFFORT,
WHICH HAS BEEN CHAMPIONED BY
FORMER AND CURRENT COUNCIL
MEMBERS, IS A HIGH PRIORITY FOR
THE CITY OF WEST HOLLYWOOD IN
2023, AS OUR WORK WITH METRO AND
LA COUNTY CHAIR SUPERVISOR
LINDSEY HORVATH INTENSIFIED, WE
ALL AGREED THAT THE CREATION OF
AN IFD WOULD BE NEEDED TO EXTEND
THE K LINE IN THE NORTHERN
DIRECTION TO SERVICE WEST
HOLLYWOOD AND ADJACENT AREAS OF
CENTRAL LOS ANGELES, INCLUDING
MID-CITY, MIRACLE MILE AND
HOLLYWOOD, AS WELL AS MANY JOB
CENTERS AND DESTINATIONS ALONG
THE WAY. WE ARE EXTREMELY
GRATEFUL TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LAURA FRIEDMAN, WHO FROM THE
BEGINNING UNDERSTOOD THE NEED TO
HAVE AN EFFECTIVE FINANCING TOOL
TO MAKE OUR RAIL PRIORITY A
REALITY. AS JUSTIN ORENSTEIN
JUST EXPLAINED, THE ABILITY FOR
OUR CITIES TO COUNT ON AN
EXTENDED AIFD MEANS THE ABILITY
TO ENGAGE IN A PROJECT OF THIS
SCALE. MANY OF YOU ARE FAMILIAR
WITH THE CITY OF WEST HOLLYWOOD,
A CITY THAT IS CELEBRATING ITS
40TH BIRTHDAY LATER THIS YEAR.
ONE YEAR OLDER THAN ME, THE CITY
HAS COME OF AGE, AND BRINGING
METRO RAIL TO THE CITY IS ONE OF
OUR HIGHEST PRIORITIES AND THE
NEXT ACTUAL VITAL STEP IN OUR
CITY'S HISTORY, AB 761 WILL
DEEPEN THE POSITIVE IMPACTS,
TRANSIT ORIENTED DEVELOPMENTS
ARE HAVING IN LOS ANGELES, AS
METRO AND COMMUNITIES LIKE WEST
HOLLYWOOD CONTINUE TO DEVELOP
INCLUSIONARY AFFORDABLE HOUSING
PROJECTS, CREATING MUCH NEEDED
UNITS OF HOUSING FOR ALL INCOME
LEVELS, WE'VE ALREADY TAKEN
STEPS TO ENSURE RAIL AND WE HÌ
EXPAND ON THIS TRADITION, WITH
FIRST AND LAST MILE PLANNING TO
IDENTIFY BIKE AND PEDESTRIAN
IMPROVEMENTS NEEDED TO EXPAND
THE REACH OF FUTURE STATIONS AND
TO IDENTIFY, WAYS THAT WE'RE
ALSO DEVELOPING TOD OVERLAYS TO
CONCENTRATE ON INCREASED HOUSING
CAPACITY AND PARTICULARLY
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AROUND
EXISTING AND FUTURE TRANSIT
STOPS. AB 761 IS ABOUT BRINGING
EQUALITY TO AN UNEQUAL
LANDSCAPE. IT'S ABOUT IMPROVING
THE QUALITY OF LIVES OF WORKING
ANGELENOS WHOM TODAY MUST GO
FARTHER AND FARTHER FROM THEIR
JOBS TO BE ABLE TO FIND
AFFORDABLE HOUSING THAT IS NOT
ALWAYS DECENT OR SAFE. THEREFORE
IN CLOSING, I ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
ANYONE ELSE WHO WISHES TO OR NØ
SPEAK IN SUPPORT. SPEAK IN
SUPPORT, RIGHT. BUT THESE ARE
THE METOOS. PLEASE COME UP. GOOD
MORNING, MADAM CHAIR. AND
MEMBERS, ANDREW ANTWI WITH CHAU
AND TÚI, SCHMELZER AND LANG HERE
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY METROPOLITAN
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY IN
SUPPORT. GOOD MORNING, JOHN
SKOGLUND WITH THE COUNTY OF LOS
ANGELES IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING, MADAM CHAIR CHRIS
MCCAULEY, ON BEHALF OF THE LOS
ANGELES AREA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE, IN SUPPORT OF MISS
FRIEDMAN'S BILL. THANK YOU.
CHAIR. MEMBERS. NICK, ON BEHALF
OF THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF GOVERNMENTS AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING. SYLVIA SOLIS CHAU, ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF WEST
HOLLYWOOD AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. OKAY. ANYONE
HERE IN OPPOSITION TO AB 761?
OKAY. SEEING NONE, WE'LL BRING
IT HERE TO ANY QUESTIONS.
SENATOR. SENATORS I TO MAKE A
COMMENT OKAY. COMMENTS WELL I
RECOGNIZE THE NEED FOR US TO
WORK ON THIS INFRASTRUCTURE. ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT WAS MENTIONED
BY ONE OF YOUR WITNESSES IS THE
INCREASE IN COST OF EVERYTHING.
AND YOU KNOW, ONE OF MY CONCERNS
IS THAT WE ARE INCREASING THE
COST OF EVERYTHING. AND A LOT OF
THAT IS SELF-GENERATED FROM SOME
OF THE POLICIES THAT WE MAKE
HERE. AND SO THEN WHEN WE GO OUT
TO FINANCE THE INCREASED COST,
IT JUST KIND OF FEEDS ITSELF.
AND AND ALL THESE INCREASED
COSTS ARE BEING FELT NOW BY, OUR
TAXPAYERS IN A, IN A GRAND WAY,
THEY ARE NOT, THEY'RE NOT
TOLERATING IT. WELL AND AT SOME
POINT WE HAVE TO LOOK AT OUR
POLICIES AND FIGURE OUT HOW WE
CAN DECREASE THE COST OF SOME OF
THESE PROJECTS SO THAT WE CAN
ACTUALLY USE SOME OF THE MONEY
THAT WE ALREADY GENERATE, TO, TO
PAY THAT, SO, YOU KNOW, THAT
BEING SAID, THIS, THE I'M VERY
FAMILIAR WITH THE AREA OVER
THERE IN WEST HOLLYWOOD AND, AND
THE TRAFFIC AND THE NEED FOR
RAIL AND THINGS LIKE THAT. AND,
AND I WOULD LIKE THEM TO GET
THIS, THIS, THIS, THESE TYPE OF
PROJECTS, IN, BUT I'M VERY, ALSO
VERY WARY ABOUT OUR OWN
PENCHENT, FROM THE STATE LEVEL
TO JUST KEEP DRIVING COSTS UP.
AND THEN WE TRY TO FIGURE OUT
HOW WE'RE GOING TO PAY FOR IT
ALL. AND SO YOU KNOW, THOSE ARE
MY CONCERNS ABOUT, THIS APPROACH
, TO, TO GETTING, YOU KNOW, JUST
FINANCING MORE AND MORE AND MORE
AND, AND THEN WE DON'T, YOU
KNOW, WIND UP A LOT OF TIMES WE
DON'T EVEN WIND UP WITH THE
PROJECT THAT WE THOUGHT WE WERE
GOING TO FINANCE. SO YOU KNOW,
I'M PROBABLY GOING TO LAY OFF
TODAY, BUT, YOU KNOW, WE'LL TRY
TO KEEP AN OPEN MIND IF WE CAN
START WORKING ON THE OTHER
THINGS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
ASSEMBLYMEMBER, DID YOU WANT TO
RESPOND OR. YOU KNOW, I DON'T
DISAGREE. COST CONTAINMENT IS
VERY IMPORTANT. AND CERTAINLY
WHEN IT COMES TO INFRASTRUCTURE,
FINDING WAYS TO STRETCH THAT
DOLLAR, WE IT'S SOMETHING THAT
ALL THE AGENCIES AND THE STATE
NEEDS TO TAKE SERIOUSLY. I WOULD
YOU KNOW, BECAUSE YOU ARE ON THE
FENCE, I WOULD REMIND THAT THIS
IS ALLOWING THEM TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF A FEDERAL LOAN BY
CHANGING THE DATES. IT'S A TOOL
THEY DON'T HAVE TO TAKE THE LOAN
IF THEY DON'T WANT TO, BUT IT
GIVES OUR CITIES MORE
FLEXIBILITY. SO I WOULD ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE ON ON THAT BASIS.
THANK YOU SENATOR DALI. I DO
HAVE A TECHNICAL QUESTION. SO I
KNOW THAT OBVIOUSLY I'M ASSUMING
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT ALLOWS
THE 30 YEAR, EXTENSION. WERE YOU
HAVE WE HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
45 YEARS NOW, AND THIS IS GOING
TO ALLOW ANOTHER 30 YEARS,
CORRECT? YEAH. THAT'S CORRECT.
THE IIJA PROVIDED FOR THIS.
RIGHT. SO DO YOUR PROJECTS. DO
THEY HAVE TO DO YOU HAVE TO GO
THE FULL 30 YEARS OR IS IT OR IS
IT CAN YOU LOOK AT THE COST
ANALYSIS OF THE JAW OF THE MONEY
THAT YOU NEED AND SAY, GO AN
EXTRA 15 OR EXTRA TEN TO
COMPLETE THE PROJECT WITHOUT
HAVING TO, PUT THAT BURDEN ON
THE ON THE RATEPAYERS? YEAH. THE
TAXPAYER WOULD BE THE LATTER
OBVIOUSLY, PROJECT CONSTRUCTION
TIMELINES OR PROJECT
CONSTRUCTION TIMELINES. BUT IN
TERMS OF THE TERM OF THE LOAN,
THAT WOULD BE SUBJECT TO
NEGOTIATION WITH THE FTA. OKAY,
OKAY. I JUST HAVE ONE QUESTION,
WHAT HAPPENS TO THE DISTRICT IF,
GOD FORBID, THE LOAN IS NOT
NEGOTIATED AND AGREED UPON? YOU
MEAN, IF THEY IF THEY CAN'T
AGREE WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT ABOUT THE LOAN AND
THEY DON'T TAKE THE LOAN, THEY
WOULD HAVE TO FIND THEIR
FINANCING ELSEWHERE. OKAY. SO
THE DISTRICT WOULD CONTINUE TO
EXIST. YOU JUST FIND A DIFFERENT
SOURCE. YOU MEAN OTHER. WELL,
THIS IS PROJECT BASED, SO THERE
SO WEST HOLLYWOOD IS ASKING FOR
THIS BECAUSE THEY FEEL THAT THEY
NEED THIS, THIS FINANCING. SO I
WOULD ASK WEST HOLLYWOOD, DO YOU
HAVE OTHER SOURCES OF FUNDING AT
THIS POINT? WE ARE LOOKING AT
ALL SOURCES OF FINANCIAL FUNDING
FOR THIS PROJECT. WE'VE
SIGNIFICANTLY INVESTED IN
LOOKING AT OUR OWN BOND RATING,
WHICH IS EXTREMELY HIGH AND VERY
WELL RECEIVED BY OUR BOND AND
OUR CREDITORS. BUT WE ARE ALSO
ONE OF OUR CITIES ON THE WEST
SIDE OF, LOS ANGELES RIGHT NOW.
THAT IS THE ONLY CITY WITH AN
ACTUAL BUDGET SURPLUS. SO WE
HAVE, GOOD LOOKS WHEN IT COMES
TO OUR ACTUAL CREDITORS AND BOND
RATES TO HAVE A REALLY HIGH BOND
RATING. AND WE'VE HAD THAT FOR,
I THINK, NEARLY, ALMOST OUR
ENTIRE CITY'S INCEPTION. GOOD.
ANYTHING ELSE YOU WANT TO ADD TO
THAT? I HAVE A LENGTHY RESPONSE
THAT I DON'T NEED DON'T
NECESSARILY NEED TO BELABOR THE
COMMITTEE, BUT I'M HAPPY TO READ
IT IF YOU'D LIKE. OKAY I'LL MOVE
THE BILL. THANK YOU. OH YES. I
APPRECIATE THE QUESTIONS AND THE
CONCERNS. AND THIS IS JUST
GIVING ANOTHER TOOL TO THIS TO
WEST HOLLYWOOD AND OTHER CITIES
SHOULD THEY CHOOSE TO USE IT. SO
I WOULD REQUEST AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU. OKAY. MOVE. BILL IS
MOVED, VOTES. MOTION IS TO PASS
TO THE SENATE FLOOR. SENATORS
DURAZZO I DURAZZO I SATO I SATO
I DOLLY. DOLLY I GLASER.
SKINNER. WAHAB. WIENER 3 TO 0.
THANK YOU. WE'LL LEAVE IT OPEN.
THANK YOU ALL. THANK YOU FOR
COMING TO SACRAMENTO BY. OKAY.
MOVING ON TO MORE, AB 1855
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ARAMBULA.
WELCOME. GOOD MORNING. GOOD
MORNING, MADAM CHAIR AND
SENATORS. STUDENTS SHOULD BE
ABLE TO PARTICIPATE IN THEIR
STUDENT BODY ASSOCIATIONS
WITHOUT THREAT TO SAFETY,
PRIVACY OR ACCESSIBILITY. K¾T
ASSEMBLY BILL, 1855 WILL
MODERNIZE THE BROWN ACT FOR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENT BODY
ASSOCIATIONS DURING THE COVID 19
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY ORDER,
AUDIO AND VIDEO TELECONFERENCING
WAS SUCCESSFULLY USED TO
INCREASE PARTICIPATION AND TO
PROTECT THE HEALTH AND SAFETY OF
OUR CIVIL SERVANTS AND THE
PUBLIC AT LARGE. HOWEVER CURRENT
PROVISIONS OF THE BROWN ACT
REQUIRE MEMBERS OF A LEGISLATIVE
BODY TO PARTICIPATE IN MEETINGS
OF THE LEGISLATIVE BODY BY
TELECONFERENCING FOR NO MORE
THAN 20% OF THE REGULAR MEETINGS
. THIS IS A BARRIER FOR STUDENTS
WHO ARE DISABLED AND WHO HAVE
LIMITED ACCESS TO TRANSPORTATION
, OR WHO ARE OTHERWISE UNABLE TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE MEETINGS IN
PERSON. AB 1855 PROTECTS PUBLIC
ACCESS AND ALLOWS FOR AN
ELIGIBLE LEGISLATIVE BODY OF A
STUDENT ORGANIZATION TO USE
ALTERNATE TELECONFERENCING
PROVISIONS IF APPROVED BY THE
BOARD OF TRUSTEES AND APPROVED
BY THE ELIGIBLE BODY, IT IS TIME
FOR US TO UPDATE THE ACT TO
REFLECT MODERN TIMES AND NEW
CHALLENGES FACED BY OUR
STUDENTS. TESTIFY LYING IN
SUPPORT IS DEBORAH NOLES,
STUDENT LEADERSHIP ADVISOR FOR
SACRAMENTO CITY COLLEGE AND COLE
MILITANO, REGION ONE REGIONAL
AFFAIRS DIRECTOR FOR THE STUDENT
SENATE OF CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. I WOULD LIKE TO WHO
WOULD LIKE TO BE IN A STUDENT.
SHE WANTS ME TO GO FIRST, SO I'M
GOING TO GO FIRST, CHAIR DURAZO
AND HONORABLE MEMBERS OF THE
SENATE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
COMMITTEE. I STAND BEFORE YOU
TODAY AS THE PRESIDENT OF THE
ASSOCIATED STUDENTS AT BUTTE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE AND THE
LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS DIRECTOR FOR
REGION ONE OF THE STUDENT SENATE
FOR CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. I'M HERE TO ADVOCATE
FOR THE PASSAGE OF AB 1855, A
PIVOTAL PIECE OF LEGISLATION
INTRODUCED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ARAMBULA AIMED AT MODERNIZING
THE RALPH M BROWN ACT FOR THE
BENEFIT OF COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENT BODY ASSOCIATIONS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA, ESPECIALLY IN THE
RURAL EXPANSES OF DISTRICT ONE,
WHICH I REPRESENT OUR DISTRICT,
WITH ITS VAST RURAL LANDSCAPES,
PRESENT UNIQUE CHALLENGES AND
ACCESSIBILITY TO AND
PARTICIPATION IN STUDENT
GOVERNMENT ACTIVITIES.
TRANSPORTATION LIMITATIONS,
INCARCERATION, AND THE PRESSING
DEMANDS OF STUDENT LIFE OFTEN
PREVENT VALUABLE VOICES FROM
BEING HEARD. AB 1855 SEEKS TO
ADDRESS THESE BARRIERS HEAD ON
BY ALLOWING FOR INCREASED USE OF
TELECONFERENCING IN STUDENT
GOVERNMENT MEETINGS, ENSURING
THAT EVERY STUDENT, IRRESPECTIVE
OF THEIR PHYSICAL LOCATION OR
PERSONAL CIRCUMSTANCES, CAN
ENGAGE AND CONTRIBUTE THE
ESSENCE OF AB 1855 LIES IN THE
RECOGNITION OF EVOLVING NEEDS OF
OUR STUDENT POPULATIONS. THE
COVID 19 PANDEMIC HAS
UNEQUIVOCALLY DEMONSTRATED THE
EFFICACY AND NECESSITY OF
TELECONFERENCING AND MAINTAINING
CONTINUITY OF GOVERNANCE AND
PARTICIPATION. IT HAS ALLOWED US
TO REACH OUT AND INCLUDE THOSE
WHO Dð DISABILITIES, CAREGIVING
RESPONSIBILITIES OR
TRANSPORTATION ISSUES WOULD
OTHERWISE BE EXCLUDED FROM THE
DEMOCRATIC PROCESSES OF STUDENT
GOVERNANCE. THIS BILL EMPOWERS
STUDENT BODIES BY ALLOWING THEM
TO ADOPT TELECONFERENCING
PROVISIONS WITHIN THE APPROVAL
OF THEIR BOARD OF TRUSTEES,
THEREBY ENSURING THAT ALL
MEETINGS ARE ACCESSIBLE,
INCLUSIVE, AND REFLECTIVE OF OUR
DIVERSE STUDENT BODY. IT
GUARANTEES PUBLIC ACCESS TO
MEETINGS AND ACCOMMODATES REAL
TIME PUBLIC COMMENTS, ENSURING
THAT OUR GOVERNANCE PROCESSES
REMAIN TRANSPARENT AND
ACCOUNTABLE. AS REPRESENTATIVES
OF THE FUTURE LEADERS OF THIS
STATE, WE MUST ACKNOWLEDGE AND
ADAPT TO THE CHANGING LANDSCAPES
OF OUR COMMUNITIES AND THE
TECHNOLOGICAL ADVANCEMENTS AT
OUR DISPOSAL. THE PASSAGE OF AB
1855 WILL NOT ONLY SIGNIFY OUR
COMMITMENT TO INCLUSIVITY AND
ACCESSIBILITY, BUT ALSO PAVE THE
WAY FOR MORE DIVERSE AND
REPRESENTATIVE PARTICIPATION IN
STUDENT GOVERNMENT. I URGE YOU
TO CONSIDER THE PROFOUND IMPACT
THAT AB 1855 WILL HAVE ON
ENHANCING THE DEMOCRATIC
ENGAGEMENT OF COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS ACROSS CALIFORNIA. LET
US TOGETHER EMBRACE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO MODERNIZE OUR
APPROACH TO STUDENT GOVERNANCE,
MAKING IT MORE ACCESSIBLE,
TRANSPARENT, AND INCLUSIVE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON AB 1855. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME AND CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS, THANK YOU FOR
LISTENING TO US TODAY. MY NAME
IS DEBORAH KNOWLES AND I SERVE
AS THE STUDENT LEADERSHIP
ADVISOR FOR SACRAMENTO CITY
COLLEGE. I ALSO HAPPEN TO SERVE
AS THE PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
CLASSIFIED SENATE. SO I HAVE AN
OUTREACH TO ALL 116 COLLEGES AND
FEEDBACK FROM ALL OF THEM. I'M
GOING TO SHARE PERSONAL STORIES
FROM SAC CITY. HOWEVER, THEY ARE
NOT UNIQUE. THEY ARE STATEWIDE
TO BE CONSIDERED SO SACRAMENTO
CITY COLLEGE HAS APPROXIMATELY
17,000 STUDENTS RIGHT NOW. AT
THE END OF FALL 2023, OUR MOST
RECENT DATA, APPROXIMATELY 51%
OF THOSE STUDENTS WERE 100%
ONLINE, NOT HYBRID AND NOT ON
CAMPUS ONLINE STUDENTS DON'T
COME ON CAMPUS FOR A VARIETY OF
REASONS, BUT IT IS A WAY FOR
THEM TO CONTINUE THEIR EDUCATION
. AS I SAID, THIS IS SIMILAR
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. THE
NUMBERS VARY EVEN AT OUR OWN
COLLEGE UP AND DOWN, BUT WE HAVE
A SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF ONLINE
STUDENTS. THE CURRENT BROWN ACT
MEANS THAT ONLINE STUDENTS ARE
EXCLUDED FROM PARTICIPATION IN
STUDENT LEADERSHIP. THEY MUST
ATTEND IN PERSON OR PARTICIPATE
REMOTELY WITH THE REMOTE ADDRESS
POSTED PUBLICLY. THIS MEANS THE
PUBLIC COULD COME TO THEIR HOME
TO JOIN MEETINGS AND USE THEIR
INTERNET ACCESS. THAT'S THE LAW
WE CURRENTLY HAVE RULES AT THE
COLLEGES THAT PREVENT US FROM
GIVING OUT STUDENTS INFORMATION
TO THE PUBLIC, SO THERE'S A BIT
OF A CONFLICT THERE AND A SAFETY
RISK. AND AS AN ADVISOR, I
ADVISE MY STUDENTS TO NOT DO
THIS. SO WE TRY TO COMPLY WITH
THE LAW IN OTHER WAYS DURING THE
PANDEMIC. WAIVERS, THE STUDENT
LEADERSHIP ENGAGEMENT OR THE
STUDENT LEADERSHIP WAS ENGAGED
AND VIBRANT. IT WAS INCLUSIVE.
IT CROSSED SOCIAL, ECONOMIC AND
CULTURAL AREAS. THIS INCLUDES
STUDENTS FROM OUR OUTREACH
CENTERS IN WEST SACRAMENTO AND
DAVIS, AND ANY OF OUR ONLINE
STUDENTS AND ANY OF OUR PEOPLE
WHO ARE JUGGLING MANY ASPECTS OF
THEIR LIFE AND CAREER,
EDUCATION. STUDENT LEADERSHIP IS
A PART OF STUDENT ENGAGEMENT
WHICH HELPS ENSURE STUDENT
SUCCESS. SACRAMENTO CITY COLLEGE
IS A LANDLOCKED PLACE WITH VERY
LIMITED PARKING PARKING. SO
TRAVELING OVER THE CAUSEWAY,
FINDING A PARKING PLACE TO JOIN
FOR A ONE HOUR MEETING, AND THEN
GETTING BACK TO YOUR SATELLITE
CAMPUS FOR A CLASS MADE
PARTICIPATION UNTENABLE UNTIL
THEY REALIZED, DURING THE
PANDEMIC, WE HAD OTHER OPTIONS.
I ALREADY SAID THAT, NOW THE
PANDEMIC HAS RESOLVED, THESE
WAIVERS HAVE BEEN LIFTED, AND I
HAVE A COUPLE OF EXAMPLES THAT I
WANT TO SHARE. TWO POSITIVE ONES
FROM SACRAMENTO CITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS. ONE STUDENT'S
GRANDMOTHER BECAME TERMINALLY
ILL, AND SHE NEEDED TO GO TO
FIJI TO CARE FOR HER
GRANDMOTHER. IN HER FINAL DAYS,
SHE WANTED TO STAY IN SCHOOL AND
STAY IN STUDENT LEADERSHIP, AND
BECAUSE IT WAS DURING THE
PANDEMIC, SHE WAS ABLE TO DO SO.
SHE WAS JOINING US AT ODD HOURS
ON HER TIME, ACTIVELY
PARTICIPATING AND DOING WHAT SHE
NEEDED TO DO FOR HER FAMILY.
OTHERWISE, SHE WOULD NOT HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO DO SO. ANOTHER
STUDENT, PLEASE WRAP UP. OKAY
THANK YOU. I WILL WRAP UP, THERE
IT, EXCLUDING SO MANY ONLINE
STUDENTS FROM PARTICIPATING IN
THEIR LEADERSHIP TAKES AWAY
THEIR VOICE. IT'S TIME TO
MODERNIZE THE BROWN ACT AND
INCLUDE THE TECHNOLOGIES THAT
CAN INCLUDE MORE PEOPLE. IT'S
TIME TO BUILD OUR FUTURE
LEADERS, AND LET'S DO SO WITH AS
MANY PEOPLE AS POSSIBLE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH, WE HAVE, ANY
OTHERS IN SUPPORT OF AB 1855?
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR. MEMBERS
AND STAFF MITCH STEIGER WITH
CFT, A UNION OF EDUCATORS AND
CLASSIFIED PROFESSIONALS ALSO IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING. CHAIR. ERIC HARRIS,
DISABILITY RIGHTS, CALIFORNIA
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING, STEPHANIE
GOLDMAN, ON BEHALF OF THE
STUDENT SENATE FOR CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES, PROUD TO
SPONSOR. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, CHAIR AND COMMITTEE, ON
BEHALF OF CALBRIGHT COLLEGE.
WE'RE IN FULL SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL. TELECONFERENCING IS AN
ESSENTIAL TOOL FOR OUR STUDENTS
TO NOT ONLY DO THEIR COURSEWORK,
BUT TO ACTIVELY AND MEANINGFULLY
PARTICIPATE IN OUR STUDENT
GOVERNMENT. THE ASSOCIATED
STUDENTS OF CALBRIGHT COLLEGE.
AS A STATEWIDE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE, A NUMBER OF OUR
STUDENTS AND SURPRISINGLY,
RESIDE IN LOCATIONS THAT WOULD
PREVENT THEM FROM PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT? SEEING
NONE. IS THERE ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION TO AB 1855? OKAY.
SEEING NONE. SENATORS, ANYBODY
WITH COMMENT OR QUESTIONS? YES,
SIR. GOOD TO SEE YOU AGAIN, SO
THIS YOUR BILL IS FOCUSED ON
STUDENT LEADERSHIP IN COLLEGE
AND BECAUSE THEY'RE SUBJECTED
UNDER THE BROWN ACT, JUST LIKE
EVERY OTHER GOVERNMENT BODY AND
TAXPAYER FUNDED BODIES AND
THERE'S A REASON FOR THAT. SO
WE'RE GOING TO SEPARATE THEM AND
SAY THEY DON'T HAVE TO, WHILE
THE OTHER BODIES ALL HAVE TO
CORRECT. WE THOUGHT THERE WERE
SOME PARTICULARS TOWARDS
STUDENTS THAT WERE DIFFERENT
THAN OTHER ELIGIBLE BODIES. AND
STUDENTS CAME TO US AND SPOKE
ABOUT, FOR EXAMPLE, IF THEY WERE
DULY ENROLLED AND WERE IN HIGH
SCHOOL AT THE SAME TIME, THEY'RE
ACTUALLY MINORS POSTING THEIR
ADDRESS HAD ISSUES, RIGHT? IF
THEY WERE SUFFERING FROM
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE, POSTING THEIR
ADDRESS EXPOSED THEMSELVES. IF
THEY HAD ISSUES WITH IMMIGRATION
STATUS, THEY AGAIN ARE EXPOSING
THEMSELVES AND THEIR FAMILIES TO
RISK. AND BECAUSE THE STUDENTS
APPROACHED US AND WANTED US TO
WORK ON THIS ISSUE, I FELT
OBLIGED AS A REPRESENTATIVE TO
MAKE SURE THAT I WAS ELEVATING
THEIR VOICE SO WE COULD BE AS
INCLUSIVE AS POSSIBLE.
UNDERSTOOD. STUDENT GOVERNMENT
IS THE LAUNCHING AND SPRINGBOARD
INTO REGULAR GOVERNMENT, AND
REGULAR GOVERNMENT IS ALL OF
THOSE THINGS. IF YOU'RE
PARTICIPATING IN A GOVERNMENT
AGENCY. WHEN I WAS ON A CITY
COUNCIL, I WAS GOING TO SCHOOL,
I WAS GOING TO WORK, I HAD NEW
KIDS. I HAD ALL OF THOSE THINGS
THAT I HAD TO TAKE INTO
CONSIDERATION. AND I WAS AT
EVERY MEETING BECAUSE THAT'S
WHAT YOU DO, IS YOU PLAN, YOU
OVERCOME OBSTACLES. IF YOU'RE
GOING TO BE A REPRESENTATIVE OF
PEOPLE, YOU NEED TO SIT WITH
PEOPLE BECAUSE IT'S A LOT
DIFFERENT BEING ON SCREEN THAN
WE SAW THIS DURING THE PANDEMIC,
AND NOT ANSWERING TO THE PEOPLE
THAT ARE OUT THERE AS USUALLY
THE PEOPLE OUT IN THE AUDIENCE,
PLAY A ROLE IN THAT INTERACTION.
THÀNH IS WHAT HELPS DEVELOP
PEOPLE INTO THE SOLID PUBLIC
OFFICIALS. AND SO, YOU KNOW, I'M
AFRAID OF CUTTING OFF THAT
LEARNING PROCESS FOR THE
YOUNGEST OF PEOPLE WHO WANT TO
START ENGAGING INTO, INTO
BASICALLY, YOU KNOW, BEING A
BEING AN ELECTED OFFICIAL AND,
AND IF THEY DON'T LEARN THERE,
WHERE DO THEY LEARN? OR IS THE
NEXT THING AS STATE GOVERNMENT
OFFICIALS, WE ALL GO TO ONLINE
AND WE NEVER SHOW UP AND WE JUST
DON'T EVEN HAVE OFFICES HERE. WE
JUST STAY AT HOME ALL DAY,
THAT'S NOT FOR ME. THAT IS A
LITTLE BIT OF A I THINK WE'RE
WE'RE KIND OF GETTING AWAY FROM
WHAT WE'RE SUPPOSED TO BE DOING,
WHICH IS SITTING IN FRONT OF THE
PEOPLE WE REPRESENT AND
LISTENING TO THEIR CONCERNS AND
WATCHING THEIR EXPRESSIONS AND
SEEING THEIR BODY LANGUAGE. AND
YOU CAN'T DO THAT ON, ON A, ON A
THING. SO ALTHOUGH I RECOGNIZE
THERE ARE ALL KINDS OF OBSTACLES
THAT CAN CREATE, OR THAT CAN BE
PRESENT FOR PEOPLE THAT WANT TO
BE INVOLVED. THAT'S PART OF LIFE
IS OVERCOMING THOSE OBSTACLES.
AND IF YOU WANT TO DO IT BAD
ENOUGH, YOU'LL DO IT. SO I, I
IT'S HARD FOR ME TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL BECAUSE OF THAT. THROUGH
THE CHAIR. IF I CAN, I WOULD
JUST REMIND US THAT OVER 50% A
QUORUM HAS TO BE PRESENT AND A
PUBLIC AGENDA WILL BE POSTED,
JUST AS OTHER STANDARDS ARE.
THIS IS SIMPLY FOR US TO TRY AND
INCREASE PARTICIPATION AND TO
HAVE THOSE MAKING DECISIONS TO
BE MORE REFLECTIVE OF THE
COMMUNITIES THAT WE SERVE. I
WOULD JUST HIGHLIGHT WE STILL
AREN'T AT PARITY HERE IN THE
LEGISLATURE, AND WE HAVE TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE MOVING BARRIERS
SO THAT WOMEN CAN PARTICIPATE
HERE IN OUR STATE CAPITAL, THAT
ALONG THROUGH OUR STUDENT BODY
ASSOCIATION. I THINK WE ALSO
HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
OPENING DOORS AND MAKING SURE
THAT ALL COMMUNITIES HAVE SEATS.
SO THAT THEY CAN MAKE THOSE
DECISIONS WHERE WE'RE SPENDING
TAXPAYER DOLLARS. AND SO I'M
EXCITED TO BRING THIS
LEGISLATION FORWARD AS I THINK
IT MOVES US A STEP IN THAT
DIRECTION WHILE MAKING SURE THAT
WE HAVE THE PROTECTIONS THAT THE
BROWN ACT WAS INTENDED TO HAVE,
WHICH IS THAT YOU'RE THERE IN
FRONT OF COMMUNITY, MAKING
DECISIONS IN THE PUBLIC EYE. AND
SO WE'VE TRIED TO THREAD THAT
NEEDLE AND AM APPRECIATIVE OF
THE BILL THAT WE HAVE BEFORE US.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, SENATOR
DARLING. SO I HAVE A COUPLE,
FIRST, I HAVE A QUESTION YOU
MENTIONED IN YOUR, ABOUT
PARTICIPATION AND SAFETY AND
PEOPLE THAT MAY NOT BE
DOCUMENTED OR PEOPLE THAT ARE
DON'T WANT TO GIVE UP THEIR
ADDRESS BECAUSE THEY'RE MINORS.
THAT SEEMS TO ME THAT IT WOULD
BE A BETTER IDEA TO GO TO THE
MEETING BECAUSE YOU DON'T HAVE
TO WHEN YOU SHOW UP, YOU DON'T
HAVE TO SHARE ANY OF THAT. YOU
YOU SHOW UP. I SERVED FOR A LONG
TIME IN LOCAL GOVERNMENT, 16
YEARS AND I THINK THE BROWN ACT
IS A GOOD TOOL. I THINK IT IT
KEEPS THE BACKROOM DEALS FROM
HAPPENING AND IT KEEPS THINGS
OUT IN THE OPEN. ALSO, THOUGH,
WENT THROUGH THE TIME WHERE WE
WERE, YOU KNOW, USING ZOOMS AND
THINGS FOR MEETINGS, EVEN HERE
IN THE CAPITOL AND, QUITE
FRANKLY, DIDN'T LIKE THAT
EITHER. BUT I WANT TO I HAVE A I
SO FIRST, CAN YOU ADDRESS THAT,
FIRST QUESTION ABOUT, YOU KNOW,
SAFETY IS IF YOU SHOW UP TO THE
MEETING, YOU DON'T HAVE TO SHARE
ANY OF THAT WHERE YOU WHERE
YOU'RE FROM. WHERE YOU LIVE, ANY
OF THAT. YOU CAN JUST SHOW UP TO
THE MEETING, FIRST, IF I CAN.
ACCESSIBILITY IS THE POINT WE'RE
REALLY TRYING TO WORK ON NOW.
SAFETY FOR SOME OF THOSE WHO
DON'T WANT TO GIVE THEIR
ADDRESS. I'M HEARING YOU, BUT
WE'RE LIMITING THEIR ABILITY TO
PARTICIPATE. IF WE'RE REQUIRING
THEM TO COME IN PERSON. I WOULD
THINK ABOUT THOSE WHO WILL
OVERLIE ISSUES WITH
TRANSPORTATION OR WITH ABILITY
ON TOP OF THOSE OTHER SOCIAL
ISSUES THAT I TALKED ABOUT. ALL
OF THOSE LEAD US TOWARDS WANTING
THIS CHANGE WHILE TRYING TO
MAINTAIN THAT YOU KEEP THAT
QUORUM PRESENT. WE THOUGHT THAT
WAS A VERY IMPORTANT PART FOR US
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE MAJORITY
OF PEOPLE WHO ARE MAKING THOSE
DECISIONS ARE THERE. I WOULD
JUST ALSO ELEVATE THIS HAS TO GO
THROUGH THE BOARD OF TRUSTEES
AND THE ELIGIBLE BODY. THOSE WHO
ARE MAKING THE DECISIONS LOCALLY
HAVE TO CHOOSE TO WANT TO DO
THIS. WE'RE SIMPLY GIVING THEM
THAT OPTION AND BELIEVE THAT
THOSE WHO ARE CLOSEST TO THOSE
DECISIONS WILL WANT TO BE AS
INCLUSIVE AS POSSIBLE, BUT
CURRENTLY THEY DON'T HAVE THIS
OPTION THAT'S AVAILABLE TO THEM.
AS THE PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY
HAS UNWINDED. MY SECOND QUESTION
WOULD BE THEN WE HAD AB 24, 49
WAS A RUBIO BILL AND 2022, WHICH
IS JUST, ACTUALLY CAME INTO LAW
JANUARY 1ST, WHICH GIVES US SOME
OF THOSE ABILITIES TO BE ABLE TO
IF YOU HAVE SOMEBODY WITH A
DISABILITY OR YOU HAVE SOMETHING
THAT ALLOW THEM TO REMOTELY. SO
CAN YOU KIND OF TALK ABOUT THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THIS BILL AND
THAT BILL? SURE. I'LL FIRST
POINT OUT, I DON'T THINK THESE
BILLS ARE IN CONFLICT. THE RUBIO
BILL WAS REGARDING THAT 20%
MANDATE THAT THEY SHOW UP IN
PERSON. THAT'S WHAT HER PILOT
HAS. WHAT WE TRIED TO DO WAS
ALIGN THE DATES OF THESE BILLS.
THAT BILL WILL EXPIRE IN 26,
WHICH IS THE SAME DATE THAT OUR
BILL WILL EXPIRE. WE WANTED TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE FELT STUDENT
BODY ASSOCIATIONS WERE SEPARATE
AND DISTINCT, AND HAD THEIR OWN
ISSUES THAT NEEDED TO BE
ADDRESSED, WHICH IS WHY WE'VE
CONTINUED TO PUSH THIS BILL SO
MUCH. BUT THOSE TIMELINES NOW
ALIGN, WHICH WILL ALLOW US TO
LEARN FROM BOTH OF THESE BILLS
AND DETERMINE WHAT STEPS WE TAKE
AFTER THAT. THANK YOU. I JUST
WANT TO MAKE A FEW COMMENTS AND
SO I, I FIND IT VERY FRUSTRATING
AS A, AS A SENATOR, THAT WE
LIMIT THE DEBATE IN OUR OWN
COMMITTEES. VERY MUCH SO. AND I
THINK IT'S WRONG, QUITE FRANKLY.
I'VE SAID THAT MANY TIMES THAT
WE CUT PEOPLE OFF AND YOU GET
TWO MINUTES TO DO THIS AND TWO
MINUTES TO DO THAT. AND THESE
ARE THESE ARE LAWS THAT ARE
STATEWIDE LAWS. AND, AND THEY'RE
THEY'RE VERY IMPORTANT. AND I
THINK THAT IF YOU KNOW, AND WE
LIMIT PARTICIPATION RIGHT HERE
IN OUR OWN BUILDING, AND I THINK
IT'S UNFORTUNATE FOR PEOPLE THAT
DRIVE OR FLY TO GET TO THE
CAPITOL TO WEIGH IN AND THEY CAN
SAY, HEY, I SUPPORT OR DISAGREE,
AND THAT'S ALL THEY GET, I THINK
IT'S GOOD TO BE IN PERSON. I
BELIEVE THAT BEING IN PERSON,
YOU CAN SEE THE BODY LANGUAGE,
YOU CAN INTERACT WITH PEOPLE A
LOT BETTER. AND SO I'M NOT GOING
TO BE ABLE TO SUPPORT YOUR BILL
TODAY, I GET WHERE YOU'RE TRYING
TO GO, BUT I THINK THE RUBIO
BILL IS A GOOD TEMPLATE FOR US
TO CHECK OUT FIRST. SO, FOR
THOSE REASONS, I WON'T BE ABLE
TO SUPPORT YOUR BILL TODAY. AND
I APPRECIATE YOU ANSWERING MY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU. SENATOR.
ANYONE ELSE? SENATOR WIENER NÓ.
OKAY. I THINK WE'RE READY TO DO
WE HAVE A MOTION. OH, WE NEED A
MOTION CLOSED. LET HIM CLOSE.
BUT WE GOT THE MOTION ALREADY
KNOW WE HAVE A MOTION. CAN WE
GET A. OH, I MOVED MOVE. OKAY,
WELL, YES. ASSEMBLY MEMBER. I
JUST WANT TO COMMENT, I VERY
MUCH AGREE WITH MY COLLEAGUES IN
TERMS, AND I'M SURE YOU DO TOO,
IS WHERE DO WE DRAW THE LINE?
HOW DO WE PROTECT THE KIND OF
INTERACTION? I THINK THERE'S A
LOT OF WAYS THAT WE HAVE
INTERACTION, THOUGH, IT'S NOT UP
TO US TO BE LIMITED BY THE
HEARING. I'M SURE WE ALL HAVE
MEETINGS WITH, DIRECTLY WITH
ADVOCATES AND OPPOSITION OAN
REPRESENTATIVES, SO OUR STAFF,
WE DIRECTLY HERE IN OUR DISTRICT
OFFICES, THERE'S A LOT OF WAYS
IN WHICH WE DO THAT. IT'S NOT
ALL IN PUBLIC, WHICH I THINK IS
THE POINT THAT THAT WE'RE TRYING
TO MAKE. SO I THANK I KNOWING
YOU, I KNOW YOU BELIEVE IN THE
SAME THING. SO WE'RE TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT HOW DO WE BALANCE IT
IN SUCH A WAY THAT IS RESPECTS
OUR PROCESS, OUR CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT PROCESS AND THE RIGHT
OF THE PUBLIC TO, TO SPEAK, BUT
THINGS ARE CHANGING, AS FAR AS,
ACCESSIBILITY, THAT'S VERY
DIFFERENT TODAY FROM WHAT IT WAS
JUST A FEW YEARS AGO, I KNOW
WE'VE VERY VÆ, VERY,
SELECTIVELY, TAKEN ON THIS
ISSUE, WE HAVE THE, THE
PORTANTINO BILL, WHICH HAD TO DO
WITH NEIGHBORHOOD CITY COUNCILS
AND ALLOWS THAT. BUT AGAIN, WITH
GUARDRAILS. SO I THINK THAT'S
WHAT YOU ARE PRESENTING WITH US,
FOR US TODAY. AND, I SUPPORT
YOU. I KNOW HOW DIFFICULT THIS
IS, BUT I THINK YOU'RE DOING THE
RIGHT THING. SO WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE? THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR, FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT. I'M APPRECIATIVE OF THE
STUDENTS TO WANT TO WORK WITH
ME, TO PRESENT THIS BILL THAT'S
BEFORE YOU TODAY. BUT
ACCESSIBILITY WORKS BOTH WAYS.
THE PUBLIC'S ABILITY TO HAVE
ACCESS, THIS IS ONE FACET OF IT,
BUT THE ABILITY TO PARTICIPATE
IN THOSE STUDENT BODY
ASSOCIATIONS ALSO IS
ACCESSIBILITY. AND FOR TOO MANY
PEOPLE, THEY HAVEN'T HAD THAT
OPPORTUNITY TO PARTICIPATE.
WHETHER OR NOT THAT'S BECAUSE OF
THEIR AGE AND THEIR MINORS OR
THEY'RE SURVIVORS OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE OR INVOLVED IN JUSTICE,
RIGHT NOW, THAT AT SOME POINT
THEY DON'T HAVE THAT ABILITY,
WHETHER OR NOT IT'S THEIR LIVING
CONDITIONS BEING RURAL OR THEIR
INABILITY TO AFFORD THE
TRANSPORTATION OPTIONS THAT ARE
BEFORE THEM, THEIR ABILITY TO
ACCESS THE STUDENT BODY
ASSOCIATIONS, WHICH ARE THE
SPRINGBOARD INTO GOVERNMENT.
WHICH IS WHY I WANTED TO
INTRODUCE THIS BILL AND WHY I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. WONDERFUL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, WE HAVE A
MOTION. WE HAVE A MOTION AND
TAKE THE VOTE. MOTION IS TO PASS
TO THE COMMITTEE ON EDUCATION.
SENATORS DURAZZO. AYE. DURAZZO I
CIERTO CIERTO. NO DOLLY. DOLLY.
NO. GLAZER. SKINNER WAHAB.
WIENER. WIENER. AYE. 2 TO 2.
THANK YOU. WE'LL LEAVE IT OPEN.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR COMING. OKAY SHE SAID. THAT
WAS A CONSENT ITEM. OH NO, IT'S
A CONSENT. OH, HERE WE GO. I
DIDN'T PUT THAT DOWN. OKAY,
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA. YEP.
THERE YOU ARE. WHAT ARE YOU
DOING OVER THERE? BE UP FRONT,
CENTER AND UP FRONT. NEXT WE
WILL HEAR AB2157. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. BONTA. WELCOME. GOOD
MORNING, CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
FIRST, I WOULD LIKE TO ACCEPT
THE COMMITTEE'S AMENDMENTS AND
APPRECIATE YOU, MADAM CHAIR, TO
HELP STRENGTHEN THIS BILL. AB
2157 IS AN IMPORTANT BILL FOR MY
DISTRICT. THIS BILL WILL HELP
THE CITY OF ALAMEDA HEALTH CARE
DISTRICT SECURE FINANCING FOR
REQUIRED SEISMIC SAFETY,
CONSTRUCTION WORK AT ALAMEDA
HOSPITAL BY 2030. HOSPITALS
ACROSS THE STATE ARE REQUIRED TO
MEET SEISMIC SAFETY STANDARDS.
IT WILL COST ALAMEDA HOSPITAL
OVER $50 MILLION TO MEET THESE
STANDARDS, AND THESE UPDATES ARE
LIKELY TO RESULT IN DISRUPTION
TO HOSPITAL SERVICES FOR
SEVERAL. FOR SEVERAL YEARS.
ALAMEDA HOSPITAL IS THE ONLY
HOSPITAL ON THE ISLAND OF
ALAMEDA THAT HAS SERVED OVER
75,000 RESIDENTS OF ALAMEDA AND
ADJOINING COMMUNITIES FOR OVER
100 YEARS. ANY TEMPORARY CLOSURE
WOULD BE DEVASTATING TO THE
RESIDENTS OF THE ISLAND. AB 2157
WILL PROVIDE THE HOSPITAL WITH
THE FINANCING IT NEEDS, ALLOWING
IT TO COME INTO COMPLIANCE WHILE
LIMITING DISRUPTION TO HOSPITAL
SERVICES AND WORKERS TESTIFYING
IN SUPPORT TODAY IS MATT MORETTI
WITH THE ALAMEDA HEALTH CARE
DISTRICT. MADAM CHAIR? YES.
EXCUSE ME, MADAM CHAIR, AND
SENATORS MATT MORETTI, WITH MJM
ADVOCACY ON BEHALF OF ALAMEDA
HEALTH CARE DISTRICT, AS THE
AUTHOR MENTIONED, ALAMEDA HAS
SERVED THE AREA FOR OVER 100
YEARS, AND IT'S THE ONLY
HOSPITAL ACUTE CARE HOSPITAL ON
THE ISLAND, THE ONLY ONE WITH AN
EMERGENCY ROOM. THE HOSPITALS
MET THEIR 2020 STANDARDS WHEN IT
COMES TO SEISMIC RETROFITTING,
THIS IS A PLAN TO MEET THE 2030
STANDARDS IN A HOSPITAL LIKE
ALAMEDA. CAN'T AFFORD TO DO IT
ON THEIR OWN WITHOUT SOME TYPE
OF FINANCING LIKE THIS. THIS
APPROACH IS NOT NEW. IT'S BEEN
DONE TWICE IN THE LAST 15 YEARS.
BILLS THAT HAVE BEEN AUTHORED
HERE IN THE LEGISLATURE PASSED
AND SIGNED INTO LAW, AND THE
LAST THING I'LL ADD IS THIS IS A
NON-FISCAL BILL, ALL COSTS WILL
BE DONE, YOU KNOW, WITH THE WITH
THE FINANCING AND THE HOSPITAL,
SO WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT. AB 2157
OKAY. THANK YOU, ANYONE ELSE
HERE IN SUPPORT OF AB 2157?
PLEASE COME UP. GOOD MORNING.
MATT LEGATE, ON BEHALF OF SEIU
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
. ANYBODY ELSE OKAY? SEEING NO
ONE ELSE, ANYBODY HERE IN
OPPOSITION TO AB 2157, SEEING
NONE. COME BACK TO THE DAIS.
YES, SENATOR. DARLING THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD.
I KNOW HOW DIFFICULT IT IS TO
KEEP HOSPITALS GOING. I WILL
MOVE THE BILL AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME AND IN SUPPORT. IT'S
APPROPRIATE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS? OKAY. SEEING NONE, I
ALSO WILL BE SUPPORTIVE. THANK
YOU FOR DOING ALL THIS WORK,
MAKE SURE WE HELP OUR HEALTH
CARE SYSTEM IN THE STATE.
ASSEMBLY. MEMBER. THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS, I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE VOTE
, THE MOTION IS Dð PASS, AS
AMENDED TO THE SENATE FLOOR.
SENATORS DURAZZO I DURAZZO I
CIERTO CIERTO I DOLLY. DOLLY I
GLASER. SKINNER. WAHAB WIENER
WIENER I 4 TO 0. LEAVE IT OPEN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE. THAT CHEN. NEXT
WE HAVE, AB 2618 ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHEN. THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR,
FOR YOUR TIME AND MEMBERS FOR
ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT AB 2618.
FIRST OFF, I WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR WORKING WITH MY
STAFF AND WE WILL BE ACCEPTING
ALL THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
UNTIL JANUARY 1ST, 2026.
GOVERNMENT CODE SECTION FIVE
THREE, 61.8 ALLOWS BUT DOES NOT
MANDATE, A LOCAL AGENCY TO
DEPOSIT UP TO 50% OF THEIR
OVERALL SURPLUS FUNDS WITH A
DEPOSITORY INSTITUTION THAT USES
RECIPROCAL DEPOSITS AS A MEANS
OF COLLATERALIZATION. USING
RECIPROCAL DEPOSITS ALLOWS THE
DEPOSITORY INSTITUTION TO ACCEPT
A DEPOSIT FROM A LOCAL AGENCY
EXCEEDING THE FEDERAL DEPOSIT
INSURANCE CORPORATION OR
NATIONAL CREDIT UNION
ASSOCIATION STANDARD INSURANCE
LIMIT OF $250,000, WHILE
MAINTAINING FULL INSURANCE
COVERAGE OVER THE ENTIRETY OF
THE LOCAL AGENCY DEPOSIT, UNLESS
EXTENDED ON JANUARY 1ST, 2026.
THE MAXIMUM 50% OF LOCAL AGENCY
FUNDS THAT MAY BE PLACED USING
POOL DEPOSITS WILL BE REDUCED TO
30. DEPOSIT STORY. INSTITUTIONS
THAT USE RECIPROCAL DEPOSITS AS
A MEANS OF COLLATERALIZED
AGAINST LOCAL AGENCY DEPOSITS OR
COMMUNITY BANKS, AND CREDIT
UNIONS OPERATING WITHIN THE
GEOGRAPHIC REGION OF THE LOCAL
AGENCY. THIS MEASURE MAINTAINS
FLEXIBILITY FOR LOCAL AGENCIES
AND BANKS AS THEY WORK TOGETHER
IN MANAGING LOCAL AGENCY FUNDS
AND IN SERVING THEIR
COMMUNITIES. AB 2618 WILL EXTEND
THE JANUARY 1ST, 2026 SUNSET
DATE TO JANUARY 1ST, 2031,
THEREBY EXTENDING CURRENT LAW
AND THE PERMISSIVE ABILITY FOR
LOCAL AGENCIES TO DEPOSIT UP TO
50% OF THEIR OVERALL SURPLUS
FUNDS WITH A DEPOSITORY
INSTITUTION THAT USE RECIPROCAL
DEPOSITS IS A MEAN OF
COLLATERALIZATION. THIS BILL
WILL ALSO REQUIRE THE CALIFORNIA
DEBT AND INVESTMENT ADVISORY
COMMISSION TO SUBMIT A REPORT TO
THE APPROPRIATE POLICY
COMMITTEES OF THE LEGISLATURE ON
THE DEPOSIT OF SURPLUS FUNDS
PURSUANT TO THE SECTION BY LOCAL
AGENCIES. HERE TO TESTIFY FOR ME
WILL BE JASON LANE, DIRECTOR OF
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS FOR THE
GOVERNMENT FOR THE CALIFORNIA
BANKERS ASSOCIATION. THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR. MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE, JASON LANE WITH CBA
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY IN THE COMMITTEE TODAY
AND APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR,
INTRODUCING THIS BILL. THIS IS A
MEASURE THAT WE WOULD CALL A
GOOD GOVERNANCE MEASURE. IT
PRESERVES THE EXISTING AUTHORITY
OF LOCAL AGENCIES TO USE
RECIPROCAL DEPOSITS TO INVEST IN
THEIR COMMUNITIES BY INVESTING
IN AND PLACING THEIR DEPOSITS IN
A COMMUNITY BANK OR CREDIT UNION
. THE THEORY, THEN, IS THAT THE
COMMUNITY BANK OR CREDIT UNION
WILL TAKE THOSE DEPOSITS AND GO
OUT AND MAKE LOANS INTO THE
COMMUNITY. AND ALSO ENSURING
THAT EVERY CENT OF THAT DEPOSIT
IS FDIC INSURED BY THE
GOVERNMENT. AND IT ALLOWS, FOR
EXAMPLE, A LOCAL AGENCY, LET'S
SAY HYPOTHETICALLY, THAT HAS $1
MILLION THAT WOULD LIKE TO
INVEST IT IN THEIR COMMUNITY
BANK OR CREDIT UNION. IT ALLOWS
THAT COMMUNITY BANK TO USE
RECIPROCAL DEPOSIT NETWORKS TO
PARTICIPATE OUT THOSE DEPOSITS
IN CHUNKS OF 250,000, TO MAKE
SURE THOSE DEPOSITS ARE FDIC
INSURED. IT ALSO MAKES SURE IT
ALSO ENSURES A LOCAL AGENCY HAS
READILY, CAN READILY ACCESS
THOSE FUNDS IN THE EVENT OF A
LIQUIDITY CRISIS. AND IS A
CHEAPER FORM OF INVESTMENT FOR A
LOCAL AGENCY, PARTICULARLY GIVEN
THE HIGH INTEREST RATE YIELDS ON
DEPOSITS THESE DAYS, VERSUS
GOING OUT TO, TO, TO THE MARKET
AND INVESTING IN, IN THE STOCK
MARKET AND INVESTMENT VEHICLES
THAT ARE NOT AS READILY
ACCESSIBLE, IN THE EVENT OF A
LIQUIDITY CRISIS AND FRANKLY,
MORE EXPENSIVE. SO WE URGE AND I
VOTE ON THIS MEASURE AND
PRESERVING THE EXISTING
AUTHORITY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ANY OTHERS IN SUPPORT
OF AB 2618? YEAH. GOOD MORNING.
NAOMI. PEDRO NHÀ, ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA CREDIT UNION
LEAGUE IN PROUD SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. ANYBODY ELSE IN
SUPPORT SEEING NONE. ANYBODY
ELSE. ANYBODY IN OPPOSITION?
SEEING NONE, MEMBERS. ANY
QUESTIONS? THANK YOU. ANY
COMMENTS? QUESTIONS SEEING NONE.
I THINK WE'LL ALL BE SUPPORTIVE.
PLEASE GO AHEAD AND CLOSE. CLOSE
THE CHAIR. RESPECTFULLY. I VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. MOTION IS
TO PASS, AS AMENDED, TO THE
COMMITTEE ON BANKING AND
FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS. SENATORS
DURAZZO I DURAZZO I CIERTO
CIERTO I DOLLY. DOLLY I GLASER.
SKINNER WAHAB WIENER WIENER. I'M
4 TO 0. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NEXT WE MOVE ON TO AB 2904. YES
AB 2904 ASSEMBLY MEMBER
QUIRK-SILVA. WELCOME. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. GOOD MORNING. GOOD
MORNING SENATORS. FIRST, I'D
LIKE TO BEGIN BY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE'S AMENDMENTS AND WANT
TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
CONSULTANT FOR WORKING WITH OUR
OFFICE, AB 20 904 EXTENDS THE
TIME FRAME WITHIN WHICH CITIES
MUST INFORM HOMEOWNERS AND
PROPERTY OWNERS PRIOR TO
IMPLEMENTING ZONING CODE UPDATES
. THE MOST COMMON TYPE OF ZONING
IN CALIFORNIA RESTRICTS CERTAIN
AREAS TO HOMES, AND SOME SMALL
BUSINESSES, IMPACTING PROPERTY
VALUES AND HOUSING SUPPLY.
CURRENT LAW ONLY PROVIDES A TEN
DAY NOTICE FOR ZONING CHANGES,
WHICH IS NOT ENOUGH TIME FOR
PROPERTY OWNERS TO UNDERSTAND
THE IMPLICATIONS. AT A TIME WHEN
CALIFORNIA FACES A HOUSING
SHORTAGE, ZONING REGULATIONS CAN
CREATE MORE RESTRICTIONS.
HOMEOWNERS NEED MORE TIME TO
GRASP HOW ZONING CHANGES MAY
AFFECT THEM. AB 20 904 ADDRESSES
THIS BY EXTENDING THE NOTICE
PERIOD TO 20 DAYS, ONLY TEN DAYS
MORE, ALLOWING PROPERTY OWNERS A
BETTER OPPORTUNITY TO REVIEW AND
RESPOND TO PROPOSED ZONING
AMENDMENTS. ENHANCING
TRANSPARENCY IN THE PROCESS.
WE'VE WORKED WITH THOSE WHO HAD
CONCERNS IN THE ASSEMBLY AND
THERE IS NO OPPOSITION ON FILE
WITH ME TODAY IN SUPPORT OF AB
20 904 AND ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
IS HAUSI CORNEO WITH THE CORNEO
STRATEGIES AND SENIOR DIRECTOR
OF GOVERNMENT RELATIONS WITH
NH█P SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. MR.
CORNEJO, WELCOME, GOOD MORNING,
MADAM CHAIR, AND MEMBERS. THE
BILL IS A VERY WE LET ME TAKE A
STEP BACK. THE REASON FOR THIS
BILL IS THAT MANY TIMES PROPERTY
OWNERS, ESPECIALLY I REPRESENT
COMMERCIAL PROPERTY OWNERS, GET
A NOTICE THROUGH THE MAIL THAT
THEIR ZONING CHANGES, THAT THEIR
ZONING CODE HAS BEEN CHANGED.
AND THE WAY IT WORKS IS IF YOU
DON'T OWN THE PROPERTY IN THE
CITY, YOU DON'T GET NOTIFIED
THROUGH THE LOCAL NEWSPAPERS,
THE SMALL PAPERS ESPECIALLY THAT
NOW HAVE, REALLY VERY LITTLE
CIRCULATION. FOR EXAMPLE, THE LA
TIMES WON'T CARRY THESE NOTICES
ANYMORE. THERE'S NO PAPER. SO
THERE'S USUALLY THE PAPER THAT,
FOR LACK OF A BETTER TERM, A
PARDON IS THE THROWAWAYS. YOU
KNOW, THE ONES THAT GET THROWN
OUT EVERYTHING IS THE ONLY PLACE
YOU GET THEM. AND SO IT CREATES
A REAL PROBLEM OF BEING NOTIFIED
ON TIME THAT YOU'RE BEING DOWN
ZONED, OR THAT YOU'RE BEING
TAKEN. SOME OF THE VALUE AND
DOWNS IN YOUR VALUE PROPERTY
GETS TAKEN. YOU ALSO TAKE A LOOK
AT THIS FROM THE OTHER SIDE OF
THE COIN. IS AND I USE MY MOTHER
AS AN EXAMPLE, A MONOLINGUAL
SPANISH SPEAKING 80 YEAR OLD
WOMAN GETS THIS LETTER. SHE'S
GOING TO WAIT FOR HER CHILD. ONE
OF US, TO COME HOME TO READ THIS
LETTER AND TELL HER WHAT IT
MEANS TO HER HOME. AND SO TEN
DAYS, IF YOU CONSIDER THE
MAILING IS TEN DAYS AND IT TAKES
2 TO 3 DAYS TO DELIVER IN A
CORPORATE OFFICE, IT TAKES 2 TO
3 DAYS INTERNALLY TO ROUTE TO
THE RIGHT PERSON. YOU'RE NOW SET
UP WITH 2 TO 3 DAYS TO RESPOND
TO THIS THING IN A PERSONAL HOME
. AND YOU. I VISIT MY MOM MAYBE
ONCE OR TWICE EVERY A MONTH, IF
I HAVE TO WAIT TO GET TO THAT TO
HER, SHE'S NEVER GOING TO GET
THE OPPORTUNITY TO DO IT. AND SO
WE'RE JUST SAYING DOUBLE THE
TIME, EXTEND THE TIME. WE
STARTED OUT WITH THIS BILL
HAVING A LOT MORE, LANGUAGE
ABOUT UPDATING TECHNOLOGY AND
DOING THESE THINGS. AND AS WE
WORK THROUGH THE COMMITTEE
PROCESS AND THE ASSEMBLY, WE GOT
REDUCED TO SAY, 20 DAYS IS THE
MAX, THAT WE'LL DO. AND SO
THAT'S WHERE WE ARE TODAY. IT'S
A VERY SIMPLE NOTIFICATION. IT
DOESN'T INCREASE COSTS BECAUSE
THEY'RE ALREADY REQUIRED TO DO
IT, AND IT DOESN'T INCREASE ANY
OTHER THING OTHER THAN SAYING
WE'RE GOING TO GIVE PROPERTY
OWNERS TEN EXTRA DAYS TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY GET NOTICES ON
TIME. OKAY. THANK YOU. ANYONE
ELSE HERE IN SUPPORT OF AB 2904?
OKAY. SEEING NONE ANYONE HERE IN
OPPOSITION TO AB 2904. SEEING
NONE ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS?
SENATOR CIARDO GOOD BILL MAKES
SENSE. I'LL MOVE THE BILL. THANK
YOU. SENATOR DARLING, I JUST
HAVE A QUESTION. SO DID YOU. I
DIDN'T I THOUGHT THIS BILL WAS
ON CONSENT, ACTUALLY. SO, BUT
ANYWAY, IS THIS THE NOTIFICATION
STILL THROUGH THE PAPER, OR IS
THERE A DIFFERENT METHOD OF
NOTIFICATION? BECAUSE THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT I'VE SEEN
THROUGHOUT THE STATE BECAUSE WE
DON'T HAVE, THE NORMAL WE USED
TO USE PAPERS. WE DON'T HAVE
THAT ABILITY. NOW, WHAT IS THE
WHAT IS THE ABILITY TO ACTUALLY
NOTIFY? IS IT SOMETHING SENT TO
THEIR HOME? IF A PROPERTY'S IF
LESS THAN A THOUSAND PROPERTIES
IMPACTED, THEN A LETTER GETS
SENT. IF IT'S MORE THAN 1000,
THEY ONLY HAVE TO PUBLISH IT IN
A LOCAL PAPER. OKAY. THANK YOU.
AND JUST TO BE CLEAR, BECAUSE I
WAS A LITTLE CONFUSED ABOUT THIS
, THIS IS ABOUT IF YOUR PARCEL
IS THE ZONING IS CHANGING,
RIGHT? CORRECT. NOT IF YOUR
PARCEL IS. AND IT'S NOT ABOUT
NOTIFYING BECAUSE OTHER PARCELS
ARE BEING REZONED. IF YOUR
PARCEL IS BEING CHANGED. RIGHT.
SO IF YOUR PARCEL IS NOT BEING
REZONED, BUT THEIR UP ZONING,
THE PARCEL DOWN THE STREET
THAT'S NOT COVERED BY THIS
NOTICE, NOT COVERED. OKAY AND IS
THIS, LIKE THE IMPETUS BEHIND
THIS? I KNOW THERE HAVE BEEN
SOME ISSUES AROUND, LIKE HOUSING
ELEMENT CHANGES AND PEOPLE'S
HOME PROPERTIES BEING PART OF A
HOUSING ELEMENT, REZONING AND
MAYBE THEY DIDN'T KNOW ABOUT IT.
WAS THAT THE IMPETUS BEHIND
THIS, THE IMPETUS BEHIND THIS IS
WE HAVE MEMBERS OF COMMERCIAL
REAL ESTATE PROPERTY OWNERS THAT
AS WE'RE DOING PLANNING CODE
UPDATES OR, ZONING PLAN UPDATES
OR, EVEN, COMMUNITY PLANS THAT
WE CALL THEM IN LÀ, THEY WERE
NOT BEING NOTIFIED THAT THIS IS
THAT THERE WAS A ZONING CHANGE
UNTIL ALL THE PROCESS. YOU KNOW,
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE'VE
HEARD IS, WELL, YOU HEARD IT
WHEN THE PROCESS STARTED. TWO
AND A HALF YEARS AGO, THERE'S A
COMMUNITY PLAN IN LÀ THAT
STARTED 12 YEARS AGO. THAT WAS
THE WHEN THE NOTICE WAS GIVEN.
SO HOW DO YOU KEEP UP THAT KIND
OF PROCESS GOING THROUGH? RIGHT.
BUT THIS IS NOT CREATING A NEW
NOTICE. IT'S JUST GIVING THEM AN
EXTRA TEN DAYS. CORRECT? OKAY.
YEAH. I MEAN, I, I UNDERSTAND
THE CONCERNS IN THE ANALYSIS AND
I THINK THOSE CONCERNS ARE, ARE
REAL. BUT GIVEN THAT THIS IS A
CHANGE FROM 10 TO 20 DAYS, I'M
WILLING TO, SUPPORT THE BILL. I
THINK THERE COULD BE A SITUATION
WHERE THIS GOES WOULD HAVE GONE
TOO FAR AND EMPOWERED PEOPLE TO
OBSTRUCT ALL SORTS OF LEGALLY
REQUIRED REZONINGS OR TRY TO
OBSTRUCT. BUT I THINK THIS IS A
THIS IS A LIGHT TOUCH AND SO I'M
WILLING TO SUPPORT IT. THANK
YOU. SORRY, NO MORE QUESTIONS,
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE, YES.
JUST RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. GREAT AND SO IT'S DO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATE AS
SENATORS DURAZZO I DURAZZO I
CIERTO CIERTO I DOLLY DOLLY I
GLASER. SKINNER. WAHAB WIENER
WIENER I 40 ZERO. THANK YOU
MEMBERS. SO WE'RE GOING TO GO
BACK TO THE ANYONE ANY ONE WHO
DIDN'T VOTE. YES SO WE ONLY
NEED, SENATOR WIENER. HEY, NICE
TO SEE YOU. YEAH WE'RE GOING
BACK TO FILE NUMBER ONE. HERE WE
GO. FILE ONE IS AB 491. WALLACE
MOTION IS TO PASS, AS AMENDED,
TO THE COMMITTEE AND JUDICIARY.
CURRENT VOTE IS 4 TO 0 WITH,
CHAIR VOTING AYE. SENATORS
GLAZER. SKINNER. WIENER WIENER.
I'M FIVE ZERO. OKAY. CLOSE THAT
NØ. KEEP IT OPEN. KEEP IT OPEN.
YES. WHO'S MISSING, SENATOR
GLAZER AND SKINNER. SORRY. OKAY
LEAVE THAT OPEN THEN, WE GO ON
TO FILE NUMBER TWO. WELL, ITEM
TWO, AB 761. FRIEDMAN MOTION IS
TO PASS TO THE SENATE FLOOR.
CURRENT VOTE IS 3 TO 0 WITH
CHAIR VOTING AYE. SENATORS
GLAZER. SKINNER. WAHAB. WIENER.
WIENER I 40 ZERO. WE'LL KEEP
THAT OPEN AND THEN CONSENT.
CONSENT MOTION IS ADOPTED.
CONSENT CALENDAR. CURRENT VOTE
IS 4 TO 0. SENATORS GLAZER.
SKINNER WIENER. WIENER. AYE FIVE
ZERO. LEAVE THAT OPEN. YEP OKAY.
WE GET RECESS. OKAY. WE'RE GOING
TO RECESS. HOPEFULLY NOT VERY
LONG FOR OTHER MEMBERS TO ARRIVE
. YEP. YOU'RE ALL DONE. YOU'RE
WE'RE GOING BACK TO THE THREE
BILLS, STARTING WITH AB 491.
MOTION IS TO PASS, AS AMENDED,
TO THE COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY.
CURRENT VOTE IS 5 TO 0, WITH
CHAIR VOTING AYE. SENATOR GLAZER
. GLAZER. AYE, 6 TO 0. WE'LL
HOLD. HOLD THAT OPEN FOR NOW.
ALL RIGHT. VÆ SKINNER AND Þ.
OKAY. GO BACK TO THAT ONE. YES.
OKAY WE HAVE TWO MORE SENATORS
HERE. AB FOUR NINE. ONE MOTION
IS TO PASS AMENDED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY, CURRENT
VOTE IS 6 TO 0 WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING AYE. SENATOR SKINNER.
SKINNER. AYES 7 TO 0. OKAY. NEXT
IS, AB SIX STYLE ITEM NUMBER
TWO. YEAH. AB 761 FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWO. MOTION IS TO PASS TO
THE SENATE FLOOR. CURRENT VOTE
IS 4 TO 0 WITH THE CHAIR VOTING
AYE. SENATOR GLAZER. GLAZER.
AYE. SKINNER. SKINNER AYE.
WAHAB. WAHAB. AYE. 7 TO 0.
CLOSE. CLOSE THAT. YEAH. OKAY.
WE'LL CLOSE THE VOTE ON THAT.
AND THEN, WE'LL GO TO CONSENT TO
CONSENT CALENDAR MOTION IS ADOPT
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. CURRENT
VOTE IS 5 TO 0 WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING AYE. SENATOR GLAZER.
GLAZER. AYE. SKINNER. SKINNER
I'M 7 TO 0. WHICH OTHER ONES DO
WE HAVE TO NUMBER FOUR. DO YOU
HAVE TO DO ALL OF THEM? YEP.
OKAY. ITEM NUMBER FOUR, AB 1855
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
COMMITTEE ON EDUCATION. ON
CURRENT VOTE IS 2 TO 2, WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING AYE. SENATORS.
GLASER. GLASER. AYE. SKINNER
SKINNER. AYE. WAHAB. WAHAB. AYE
5 TO 2. NEXT WE GO. ITEM SIX AB
2157. MOTION IS TO PASS, AS
AMENDED, TO THE SENATE FLOOR.
CURRENT VOTE IS 4 TO 0 WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING AYE. SENATOR GLAZER
. GLAZER. AYE. SKINNER. SKINNER.
AYE WAHAB. WAHAB. AYE. 7 TO 0.
VOTE IS CLOSED. GO TO ITEM EIGHT
AB 2618. CURRENT MOTION IS TO
PASS, AS AMENDED, TO THE
COMMITTEE ON BANKING AND
FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS. CURRENT
VOTE IS 4 TO 0, WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING AYE. SENATOR GLAZER.
GLAZER. AYE. SKINNER. SKINNER.
AYE WAHAB. WAHAB. AYE. 7 TO 0.
THAT'S IT, NUMBER TEN. NUMBER
TEN. THAT WAS PULLED. OH THAT'S
RIGHT. OKAY. ITEM TEN AB 2904 IS
OUR LAST BILL. MOTION IS TO
PASS, AS AMENDED, TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE IS 4 TO 0 WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING AYE. SENATOR GLAZER
. GLAZER. AYE. SKINNER. SKINNER.
AYE WAHAB. WAHAB. NÓ 6 TO 1. NO
WE ALREADY DID THAT. YEAH THANK
YOU. OKAY. CLOSE ALL. YEP. OKAY.
CLOSE ON ALL OF THEM, ON ALL
THE, BILLS, THANK YOU TO ALL THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO PARTICIPATED IN
PUBLIC TESTIMONY TODAY. IF YOU
WERE NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY, PLEASE
SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
SENATE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
COMMITTEE OR VISIT OUR WEBSITE.
YOUR COMMENTS AND YOUR
SUGGESTIONS ARE VERY IMPORTANT,
AND WE WANT TO INCLUDE YOUR
TESTIMONY AND THE OFFICIAL
HEARING RECORDS. THANK YOU.
APPRECIATE YOUR PARTICIPATION.